で では早速入ります 忘れてはならない 5つの現実という
今日は私のあれやこれやとか話はございません
直接経典一つ できるだけ省略しますが
そのまま解説していきます
現実を常に意識すれば
煩悩は収束するという
まあ現実見れば まあ煩悩がなくなるんだという
ずいぶん楽な話なんですね
まあ仏教というのは本当に人間に理解しにくい
大変な難しい教えでもあります
しかし 難しい教えでもないんです
とてもシンプルです もしかすると
世の中でこれほどシンプルな教えがないと言えるほどシンプルなんですけど
どうも人間には理解できないんですね
この理由というのは 我々頭の中でいっぱい概念がありまして
この勉強するということは
概念からもう書き直すんですね
何を勉強しようと思っても
自分の頭にすでに入っている概念を書き直す
書き直して新しい概念を作ってしまうと言ったっても
別に新しくないんです
同じブロックを別な形に組み立てただけ
だから本を読んでいる時でも
やっぱり私たちはさっぱり未だかつて聞いたことがないアイデアが入っているとさっぱりわからないんですね
例えば 見たこともない漢字が出てくると
これはわからないんですね
私はあまり漢字で読まないんですけど
まあやっぱり英語で読んでみる時でも
全く聞いたことがないフレーズやらね
単語やら出てくると なんだこりゃとわからなくなる場合ありますね
その時は脈絡で前後関係でこうではなかろうかと理解しますよ
ということは 結局すでに自分の頭の中の概念
中にある概念で理解をするんですね
仏教の場合は 人間のこの概念がそもそも間違いがあるんだと
概念全部 そこをちょっと調整しなくちゃいけないんだよと
いうことで 概念を使わず
事実ありのままに見てみましょうということだから
これ相当難しいということになりますね
例えば 人が走ってきて自分の体にぶつかったとします
我々の概念は 何々人がもう不注意で走ってきてぶつかったんだと
もうかなり痛くなったんだと
それからなんだこの野郎と
あれこれやと で 向こうは謝りなさいと謝る
謝っても済むも済むもんかと思いますか？とかね
どこまでこの概念の組み立て進む行くかわからないんですね
仏教の場合は触れた 痛みが生まれたという程度の概念なんですね
それから触れることによって痛みが生じる
そこでストップなんです
なんだこの野郎とかはいかないんです
そこで痛みは感じてますから
あ 痛みはじわじわと消えていくものやと
あ これが消えるんだと
そのようにどんな感覚を感じてみて
あ すごい気分がよくいい感じが生まれても
触れた気持ちのいい感覚が生まれた
あら あれ消えていくんだと
その世界なんですね 仏教は人はいないんです
そちらに何の煩悩も葛藤もないんです
ありのままに  100%の確かな事実だけ見るんですね
推測はしないんです データに基づいて
で そういうスタンスからの仏教だから
やっぱりわからないということになってしまいます
はい 今日の経典の名前はね
ずいぶん短い名前でね
アビンナパッチョエッキタッバッターナスッタンというね
ローマ字で長く感じたってもね
私たちにとってはそんな大した長い経典名前ではありませんね
アビンナンパッチョエッキタッバンという言葉というのは
我々仏教の世界ではよく使っている単語なんですね
はい このタイトルね 分析してみましょう
あまり経典のタイトルなんか分析しない方がいいんです
あのタイトル名前を入れる場合はほとんど真剣じゃないんです
ただ あの経典とこの経典の差
違いますよ それだけで十分ですね
たまに本当に内容を説明するタイトルにする場合もあるし
あるいは誰かの名前を付けたりもしますね
ウパーリスッタンって
ウパーリというのは人の名前なんですね
だから内容は何やとわからないんですね
だからあまり経典のタイトルは真剣に分析しない方がいいんですけど
この場合は内容を表現しています
アビンナっていうのは常にということで
まあそっちをやってくださいっていう意味でね
always frequently という意味で
そこでパッチャヴェッカティっていうのは動詞なんですね
これはあの それを観察する
考慮する 思い浮かぶ で
まあ人間というのはいろんなことを思い浮かびたいんですね
妄想したいんですね あれは仏教を認めません
何でもかんでもあれやこれやと思う感じはダメやと
しかし いくつかの項目を繰り返し繰り返し思い出しなさいよと
妄想する代わりに これをスーッと頭の中で回転させてみなさいということで
これパッチャヴェッカティっていうんですね
英訳で言えば このパッチャヴェッカティというのはレトロスペクションなんですね
イントロスペクションという単語もよろしいんですけど
ちょっとレトロという言葉がありますからね
まあこれは出さない方がいいんじゃないかなということで
まあレトロスペクトっていうのは
自分の過去を思い出すことなんですね
ですから オブザーブ ケンシードー
ポンデルというね まあリフレクト
まあリフレクトといえば
ちょっと振り返って考えるっていう意味になるんですね
ポンデルっていうのはすごい深くで考えることで
まあケンシードーっていうのはそれほど深くないんだけど
あ そういうことですかねという
ああ なるほど そういうことかというふうな意味を表現することがケンシードーですね
オブザーブっていうのは
よくよく見て こうだからこうなってる
こうだからこうなってるというふうに調べることですね
英語はうるさいんですね
はい それでパッチャヴェッキタッバッターンということで
次の単語になりますね
このタッバ パッチャヴェッカティではなくて
パッチャヴェッキタッバですね
タッバっていうのは動詞の後ろに使う言葉で
これはこのするべきって意味なんですね
だからべきだけなんですね
動詞がありますからね
オート ハブ トゥ マストというふうな英訳すればね
ターナっていうのはプレイスという意味なんですけど
本当は  この場合 箇条 項目
ポインツ コンディション
シチュエーションというふうな意味になるんですね
ということはまとめてみるとありましたっけ
あ スッタ スッタンデの経典ですね
まあまあ これは日本語でも訳してます
スッタンデの本当の意味はエキスポジション
ディクラーションというね
かなり公言することですね
公で発表することなんですね
すごくまとめて だからすごい言葉に気をつけて
意味の並び替えも気をつけて
公に公に発表するっていう意味なんです
で 意味はまとめると常に観察する
観察すべき項目の発表
これ 現代的な解説はそういうふうになります
解説というか 日本訳はね
はい これで人間とはというところから始まります
人間というのは嘘大好き
騙されることを期待する
お世辞 おだてることは大好き
現実は知りたくないんですね
真理に背を向けるんですね
これって人間のまあ普通誰にでもあることなんですね
なんでそうなってるかというと
隠したいことがあるんです
なんでお世辞大好きですか？なんで嘘大好きですか？と
まあ嘘大好きと言ってもちょっと意味が違います
あんた嘘つきやって意味じゃないんです
我々は嘘が好きなんです
人が嘘を言っていると喜んで聞いてるんです
おだてるとずいぶん気分がいいんです
だからそこは逆に逆さまにとって
君丸さんでしたっけ？あの漫画家がいてね
おばあさんに何歳ですかと
歳 あ よく見えると だから普通はえー
まあ見えませんねと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
だから それ逆に笑い取るために
あの人が歳ああ よく見えます
いきなり だから 歳の人には歳で見えるということは事実かもしれません
だけど それは言ってあかんというね
それが嘘つきということなんです
別に人は嘘つきだっていう意味じゃないんです
それは別に道徳的な問題ですからね
我々は道徳的な嘘を置いといて
日常も嘘だけで固めた人生を送ってますね
おだててほしいんですね
いつでも何か隠したいことがあるんです
これは生きることは相当大変で
やっと生きてるという状態なんです
本当に見てみると 生きるということは相当大変なことなんです
やっと生きているんです
これ隠したいんですね
何をやってもうまくいかず
不満に満ちている これが事実ですね
しかし これ隠したいでしょ
暗示 マインドコントロールがないと生きて生きられないんですね
見たくない人生なんか見ると
もうもう大変苦労ばっかしで
そこで嘘でもいいんだから
なんとかごまかってくださいと
そういう嘘で慰めてもらいますね
末期状態の患者さんにでも
お医者さんが結構信奉がよろしいと言ってますよと言ったら
ああそうですかと 信奉って病気の信奉かどうかわかりませんだけど
だから理性のある患者は何の信奉ですかね
健康になることか 病気になることや病気になることやと言っちゃうと大変まずいんですよ
だからこれが世間の状況なんですね
だから常識守れ守れといっても
嘘つきということなんです
騙せと人々を ではっきりものを言う人っていうのは
もう行儀が悪いわね 社会常識知らないわとかね
言葉は荒っぽいわとか
いろんなこと言われるんですね
どちら取ればいいんですかね
この騙されてごまかして嘘で生きていると
ますます人生大変になるんです
だから最近日本の状況なんですけど
最近じゃないんですけどね
まあ年 20年ぐらい  15年ぐらいですけどね
ずっと日本は経済大国世界一というふうに暗示かけてきたんですね
現実は見ないんですね
私が調べたところで こんなにもう金が空から降ってくる国ではないし
穴を掘ったら石油はバンバン出てきて金が流れてくる国でもないし
まあ農業だけはね まあそんなにいくらでもね
まあ栽培できますけどね
日本の土は素晴らしいんですね
土と水ですね で それはついてます
文句ないんですね 自慢できます
しかし そこは置いといて
フランスから水を買って飲むんだからね
あれ 硬水ですけど 私は飲みませんよ
レビアンはお腹が壊れます
で 単なる暗示かけてくれるんですね
日本は経済大国やと 現実はそうじゃなくて
一人一人が朝から晩まで必死で仕事をしているんです
自分の仕事に適した給料ももらってないんです
日本の給料は高いんですよ
世界水準で見れば 高いんだけど
世界水準で見ると 日本人はものすごく仕事を頑張っているんです
だから 50万給料もらう人はあの優秀な人々なんです
本当はものすごい  100万ぐらいもらっても悪くないぐらい仕事はしているんですね
ということは タダで働いて金集まって集めているような感じでしょうね
それで経済大国やと自慢しても
これ違うんでしょうに
だから現実見たならば
私たちは他の国々の人々よりも頑張らなくちゃあかんやと
1 日 8時間の仕事では日本は成り立たないんだと
ちょっとの勉強では成り立ちませんよと
この経済 贅沢なこの状況を維持するためには
日々頑張らなくちゃいけないんだよと
これはとてももう我々は毎日頑張ることで成り立っているものだということを教えてあげた方がやっぱり暗いんですね
言葉は それでどうなってますかね
今は 経済大国じゃなくて
もう赤字大国 信じられないほどものすごい恐ろしく赤字で
それでよく外国人に言わせ
もう宣伝していることというのは
この節約っていうことは日本ではある
美しい言葉ですと なんか誰かの女の人がもったいない
なんだらかんだら言いながら大騒ぎしちゃったんです
アフリカのね まあうるさかったんで
私はあんまり興味がなかったしね
で これ国際言葉にしますとかね
だから日本人もすごく気分になっちゃって
やっぱり日本の言葉はね
これノーベル賞を取っている人もよく使ってますよとかね
じゃあ現実どうですかね
日本の 本当に皆様方もったいないという生き方で生きてますかね
節約っていうのは知ってますかね
全くも違うんです 無駄遣いのプロなんですね
あの事業仕分けなんかあんまり見てないんで
ちらちら見ると あの今まで何兆もお金無駄遣いしてた
でも狂暴ですね できることなら大臣たち殺すと思いますよ
大臣たちも同じ日本人だからね
はっきりものを言わないんですね
国は赤字大国やと それ考えなさいよと
あんた方のこの無駄なことにね
まあお金あげて まああげたっても悪くないんだけど
もうできませんよと だから
国のために給料はいくらか下げたっても
どうしようもないでしょうにと
あなたよりも政府よりも国民の方が国の方が大事ではないかとハッキリ言っちゃえばいいのに
それを言わない 言ったら負けますからね
選挙で ということは やっぱりみんな無駄遣いのプロで
あのなんですね だから無駄遣いできないはずなんです
無駄遣いっていうのは
あの どこでしたっけ？とか
あの外国 アラビアの国がありまして
あのえ ドバイとかね あんなアホがやったってもいいんだけどね
世界一高い建物を作るぞとか
勝手にしなさいと で また国が倒れると
周りのアラビアの国々からお金もらって
やっぱりそうやってこの地球の財産食いまくって無駄遣いするのは
これ自体も罪でしょうし
日本の方々そうじゃないでしょうに
自分の腕の力で柵をして
それは合法的なんです
仏教の教えに従って合法的なんです
自分の腕と頭の力で食べているんだと
素晴らしいんですが しかし
頭と頭と腕で食べているということは
毎日頑張らなくちゃいけないんです
自動的に降ってこないんです
だから そういうふうな生き方をしたならば
この経済不振とか何にもならないんですね
余計なことをいろんな国々の人々がやっている
無知な無駄なことってやろうとしないんですね
もっとしっかりとやるはずでしたけどね
今ね 中国との関係もね
そういうことで悪くなっていてね
本当にすごい まあ心配は心配ですけど
だからこの社会常識やと思ってね
ごまかしたり暗示かけたりすることっていうのは
どんな側面から見ても
危険なものなんです  ブッダにはそんなに世間のことはあまり興味はないんだけど
ブッダは人間としてのこのごまかしについて語っているだけで
だからどちらかというと宗教の管轄ですから
宗教家も一番上手に人を騙すんですね
永遠な天国の話を持ってくるんだけど
条件付き お金なんぼくれるのかいっていうことで話が済むんですね
天国に行くことは 見る限りおかしいでしょうに
天国あるならば それは万人に入ることができるものであるならば
なぜ一部の人々だけ入ることが可能な天国あるんですかね
そこで この一部の人間の中に入りたくて
一般のアホな人々はすごい苦労するんですね
だからそこで商売成り立っちゃうんですね
そういう風ないろんなことで私たちはこの嘘で生きてますね
暗示で生きてます マインドコントロールで生きてます
ということは もう知恵は知識っていうのはもうないということになりますね
現実見ると気持ちはわかります
例えば私も人間の気持ちはわかります
なんでそんなにも神頼みやらね
もうあれやこれやともう足かせ手かせ
ありったけの束縛で苦労しているのかと
気持ちわかりますよ 誰かが病気になったところで
もうなかなか治療はないし
うまくいかないし 金もないし
あの状態がね 精神的にすごいもう悩んでいる状態なんですね
だからどんな神でもいいんだから
もう頼むんですよ で 神に頼んでも病気治らなかったら神を恨めばいいのに
それ常識でしょうね この野郎のお祈りしたんですけど
何もやってくれなかったと
とんでもない神やと 言ってなんかポスターでも貼っちゃえばね
なになにこの八幡神宮の神はバカ野郎と
そこまで今理性がないんですね
なぜかというと そこでまた脅しが入ってきて
侮辱したら罰が当たるよとお願いしたら行ってくれ
やってくれなかったら
侮辱したら罰が当たる
どういうことですかね
俺はあなたの頼みはやってあげませんだけど
侮辱したらあなたを天罰するぞとかね
冗談じゃないでしょうに
それでも人間がいくら結果がなくても祈りはするし
神頼みはするし それっていうのは
ちょっと蓋を開けてみると
生きることは本当に大変で
どうしようもないということなんです
現実は 憐れむべきところなんです
だからブッダは憐れみを教えているんです
神様がついてるんだから
仏様がついてるんだから気にしないでくださいという暗示ではなくて
やっぱり大変ですねとかね
考えてみればね あなたにはもう相当な問題があって
それにしたら私にはこういう問題があって
何々さんも考えて大変でとかね
どういう風にこの憐れみというかね
憐れみって言うんですかね
もうコンパッションですね
優しさ そちらには暗示がないんです
だからお嫁さんがね この周典さんのせいでもう全くうまくいかないんだ
もうもう家庭の内容はもう何に幸せもないんだとかね
あれやこれやと言っちゃうと
まあそれはそれはもうその通りでしょうと
あんた自分思う通りにはうまくいかないでしょうしね
まあだから舅様にしたってもうね
まあ息子 自分も息子ですからね
あの男はあなた言うことを聞くか
母親が言うことを聞くか
よくわからないでしょうにと
大変でしょうと で 逆にじゃあ舅様は楽ですかと
舅さんにもそれなりに大変でしょう
あの人も ということで
結局はみんな同じ いろんなもう苦しみを味わいながらやっと生きてるんだっていうことが知ると
我々はこの神頼みではなくて
自然にこの優しさというものが生まれてくるんですね
心配する気持ちが生まれてくるんですね
生命に対して これがないでしょうにね
やはり騙すことが大好きだが
騙されるのは嫌なんですね
また矛盾 騙すことって大好きなんです
しかし 騙されることが嫌なんですね
しかし 他人を騙そうともする
それから いつでも我々は人を騙すということで生きているんです
じゃないと思うでしょ？なんでお化粧するんですかね
それさえも騙しでしょうに
だからまあ人生全体的に他を騙すためにやってるんです
例えば ある女性がすごく見事にプロに頼んでお化粧して
もうしっかり体を作ってみんなの前に出てきたら
まあたまげたもんで すごい美人
美しい そこでもう一人の女の人はね
あれはまあ化粧しているんだから
すっぴんで見たこと見た時はもうゲロが出るでしょうとか
なんとか言うんですね
だから なんでそういうことを言うかというと
騙されるのは嫌だということなんですね
こんな金もかかって 日本の一流のもうもうそういうね
美容師というんですかね
そういう人に頼んでね
もうまたもうデザインした服も着てね
偉そうにもう今もう振り回っていますけどね
普通はもう打ったことない
ただのババアだと と言いたくなるんですね
ということは 騙されるのは嫌だ
その その言葉言ってる人も結局はお化粧しているんですね
だからこのお化粧の例はとてもいいんです
なぜならば 我々は何のことなく毎日やっていることだから
私はやってませんけど
あの 何のことなくやっていることなんです
それさえも騙す行為なんです
その上のことは言うまでもないでしょう
人間が築いた世界はこのようなものです
だから事実隠そうという世界を築いているんです
だからいつでもぶつかる
科学者が何やろうとすると言うと
本当に何が起きているのかもう探したくなるんですね
それと同じ科学者の気持ちはまた反対なんですね
隠そうという だからいつでもなんか矛盾だらけの対立だらけの世界なんですね
科学者が研究すると 宗教家が大反対する
で 研究が成功して役に立つ場合は
何にも言わないで こそこそとその科学の恩恵をもらいます
もらって次の研究に邪魔する
それもうまくいって人が助かっている場合は
これは素晴らしいことやとかなんとか言って科学者を褒めることはしませんよ
で ノーベル賞はインチキですけど
まあバチカンではね あの聖人認定しますね
頭イカれたバカどもはずっと認定し
最近も何人 2  3人認定しましたけど
みんなどうでもいい人種の人間ですけど
で 調べたら科学者一人も認定していないんですね
だって この細菌を発明したり
あれやこれやとかする人々は人類が助かってますから
一人も認定しないんですね
だからこの善人認定する人っていうのは何人助けてあげたんですか？というと
何のこともないでしょうに
宗教の枠を破って人を助けている
動物も病気になったら現代医学で治療できるようになっていて
イエス様がみずからやる一ことすごい奇跡だったらね
今空を飛んでいるでしょうに
イエス様にはできなかったでしょうに
だったらライトブラザーズでもね
もうもう死んじゃってるんだからどうったことはないし
もう善人としてね 聖人として認定しちゃえば
あなた二人の努力によって
今人類は随分助かってますよと
ローマ教皇様も使ってますよと
飛行機は で そちらでは非科学的な奇跡
何かを起こしてほしいということがあるんですね
これ自体怪しいんですからね
まあだからこの世界っていうのは
私は言いたいのは宗教批判というよりも
人類の生き方というのはいつでも対立で対立で対立で成り立っているんだということなんです
はい なんでそれを言ったのかというと
そちらの全く反対のことをこれから説明しますからなんですね
仏教は暗示かけることではなくて
マインドコントロールではなくて
目覚めることを 語ってますね
目覚めることはブッダの提案です
無知なままでは苦しみの悪循環から脱出できません
目覚めた人は俗人を超えているんです
だからブッダの教えによって目覚めてもらっちゃえば
一般の方々にはかなわない桁違い
すごい優れた人間になってしまいます
騙すこともなく 騙されることもなく生きていられる立派な人間になります
認めようとしないが 常に観察するべき５つの現実
はい これから経典の中身に入ります
今までちょっとイントロダクション
経典に入る前のこれから中身に入ります
仏弟子たち皆に推薦してやります
これが 経典の冒頭 パンチマーニビッケエターナーニアビンナンパッチウェキタッバーニイッティアワプルセーナワガハッテーナワパッボジテーナワっていうことで
すね
比丘たちよ 出家と在家の女性も男性も
常に観察するべき箇条が５つあります
はい これわかりますか？普遍的に語っています
出家であろうが在家であろうが
男であろうが女であろうが関係ないんだよと
これはみんなに平等な共通している真理で
これは観察してほしいんだと
で 箇条１ ジャラダンモミジャランアナティートーティアビンナンパッチウェキタッバン
私は老いる性質の者であり
老いは超えてないと常に観察するべきです
老いた人のあれ アートクリップアートを探したんですけど
なかったんです もう嫌ですね
老人の絵描くの そこまで騙しなんです
この誰も見たくないんで
自分が老いる性質 性質っていうのはネイチャー
性質っていうのは このダンマっていうジャラダンマ
どんなものでも老化するのは自然法則なんです
この自然法則であること
もう絶対これ避けられないんだと
私は超えてないんだと
自分というものっていうのはもう生きているものだからね
だからこの生きているっていう場合は老いるっていうことを老いることを生きること
同じことでしょうに 赤ちゃんが成長するということは老いることでしょうに
だから生まれた瞬間から老いて老いて老いていくんですね
これごまかしで あ 成長しているんだと
すくすく育っているんだとかね
とんでもない嘘を言うんですね
私は冗談で子供たちにね
ちょっと大きくなって
あんた結構年取ったねとかね
子供たちはニコッと笑うんですね
別になんのこともなく
この坊主は嫌なことを言うんだっていうことは全然ないんです
だから誰も言わないことを言うんだから
どう反応すればいいかと
これには負けてはあかんやと思って
なんとか考えるだけで
まあちょっと大きくなってきて
それでも甘えようとしちゃうと
私はそれで攻撃するんですね
もう年寄りとは遊びませんよとかね
年寄り抱っこする どんな世の中抱っこしますか？とかね
で だからまあ でお母さんとお父さんとこ行ったらもう嫌な顔するんだけど
私は気にもしません 私
本当のこと言ってますからね
そういうことで 生まれた瞬間から老いて
老いて 老いていくんで
それ事実なんですよね
現実ですね これ認めましょうよと
2番目は 病理ダンモヒビャーディンアナティートーティアビンナパッチェッティタッバ
私は病に落ちる性質であり
病いを超えては超えてないと常に観察するべき
肉体を持って体持ったらこれは病気になる
超えてないと そこで病気の定義
ちょっと覚えておきましょう
私たちは病気というのは
今 このもうこのなんとか
この画であるような感じで
もう倒れた時なんですね
しかし 仏教の定義で病気っていうのは
手当てしないと死ぬ ならばそれが病気なんです
別にあまり不思議じゃないでしょうね
だって医学的にも同じことでしょうに
手当てしないと死ぬ ならばその現状に病気というということは
仏教から見ればお腹が空くことも病気なんです
手当てしなかったら死にますよ
喉が渇くことも病気なんです
しかし 我々の社会は それは元気だと言うんでしょ？あまりにも非科学的ですね
科学者は お腹が空くこと
ああ 元気ですね あれ 元気じゃないんです
お腹が空いてなんとか手当てしないと死にますよ
それ大便小便とかしなくちゃあかんでしょ
あれは仏教では病気なんです
でも お医者さんに聞いてみてください
自分が何のこともなく
よくあの もうその機能はちゃんと機能していますよと
介入はもう見事にですよと
排便も問題ないんだと
ああ 健康でなりきれた
あの人が言うでしょうに
違うんです もしそこをできなかったら死んじゃいますから
ということで 仏教の病気の定義っていうのは結構幅広くて
もうぴったし論理的に言うんですね
手当てしなかったら死ぬならば
排便ももう病気だと くしゃみも病気だと
ジガッチャビパーサウッチャーローパッサとか
まあそういう全部入ってます
高血圧とかね そんなそれは病気ですけど
がんとかね 昔もがんがあったみたいですね
だって経典にがんも入ってます
病気のリストの中に ということは
呼吸することも病気になりますよ
常に酸素を入れてあげないと死にます
では 呼吸することは生きていることでしょうに
だから病がなければ命がないんですね
なんかすごい矛盾でしょ
病が命を支えているんです
ちょっと全国言えば 病のおかげで元気ですと
禅文学を真似て言えばね
病のおかげで元気でいますと
いうことは現実なんです
我々はちゃんと呼吸できて
排便小便もちゃんとうまくいって
お腹もちゃんと空いたりして
で 喉も喉が渇いたりして
それからちゃんと汗も出たりして
ああ すごい健康やと 例えば運動しても汗が出ないとこれも病気なんです
で 汗が出ることも病気なんです
出ないことも病気なんです
汗ばっかり出ちゃうと
脱水症状で死ぬ可能性もありますね
汗が出ないと なんとか
なんて言いますか ヒートストロークというかね
体の中ね 熱が放出できなくて
脳がイカれてしまいます
とても危険です だから生きること全部なんか病でできてますね
細胞一個もやっぱり栄養を取らないと
呼吸しないと一個の細胞でも
やっぱり病気が組み立てて生きて命という風になっているんですね
なのに私たち人間どもは
ああ 病気なんか嫌だとかね
私は病気にはかかりません
健康もそのままやとと思ったりする
これはとんでもないアンチなんです
はい サンサンが言わなくてもわかりますね
マラナダンモーミマラナンアナティートーティアビンナンパッチキタッバン
私は死す静寂であり 死を超えていないと常に観察するべきですね
だから病気でできていて
老いることでできていて
壊れるに決まってるでしょう
なのに私たちは頭がおかしいんだからね
精神的にイカれているんだから
我々の人生プログラム
人生企画はいつでも我は死なないという前提で作るんです
例えば 空気のきれいなきれいな水のある富士山も見えるところで
まあ土地を買って家を作りましょうと
そこで畑でも野菜作って
まあ退職後楽しもうと思うと
それ全部我は死なないと前提で立てる企画なんです
来年の夏はどこ行こうかなとかね
中国に行く予定でしたけど
中国人は嫌だから じゃあフランスにしましょうとかね
こんな計画は私は死なないという前提で成り立っているでしょ
だからわかりますかね
我々人類の企画 計画 思想
プログラム 希望 願望 すべて我は死なないという素晴らしい事実に基づいてできているんです
何言うんですかね いかに私たちは嘘の世界で生きているかっていうことなんです
はい カジョヨン イラストではよくわからないんですね
カジョヨンは サッビーメーピーマナーピーナナーバウヴィナーバオーティアビンナンパッチェキタブ
私の愛するもの 好きなもの
すべてが変わるものであり
離れてゆくものでありと
常に観察するべき 自分が好きなもの
愛するもの 欲しいものっていうのは全部変わっていくんですよね
まあ自分も変わりますけど
気持ちだけはそのままで保とうしているでしょうに
だからこれで人間がものすごく悲しんだり
嫉妬したり 怒ったり 喧嘩したり
離婚したり あれやこれやと
どれを 人間というのは何か好きなものを揃ってくると
私は本当に神様に恵まれているんだとへっちゃらで言うんです
オーディション抜けたんですけど
あの 900人見ましたと
選ばれたのは一人で 私だけやと
やっぱり神様に恵まれているんだと
あれ 神様に恵まれるという言葉を聞いた時は
私のもうお腹が痛くなって
もう本当にぶん殴りたくなるんですね
なぜかというと これすごい失礼な言葉なんですね
なんで大勢の人が苦しんで金がなく
何のこともできなくて
ホームレスになったりもしていて
自殺もしたりしている間で
たった一人だけ  18歳聞いたら 18歳
もう財産はまあまあ軽々と 15億ぐらいありますよとか
18歳で自分がお母さんに家を買ってあげたと
いくらかかったと  あれは億ですね
まあ大したことじゃないと
という人もいる この人は神様に恵まれているというでしょ
それで大勢の人々はろくに食べるものもない
寝る暇もない 仕事もない
そんな現実の中で一人だけってどれほど失礼な
恐ろしい 残酷な気持ちですか
別に神のことで 私は別にどうったことないんだけど
人の信仰であるならば
この人間として この残酷なこと
時々私にもいろんな人が嫉妬することがありますけどね
あなたにはいっぱい金があるんじゃないかなとかね
私はだから人の知識 能力を見てね
金が私には要りませんよ
だから 要らない人にとっては 1,000円あったっても
それ金だよと だからあなたは欲しい欲しいと思っているんだから
あんた貧乏やと これで頭の病気だと
金持ちかそうでないかということは
あの数字で稼げるものじゃなくて
頭の病気やと で 私は貧乏やという人がただ単に病気だけなんです
で またある人に答えたのはね
あのね 金が欲しいと思っちゃうと 1円も入ってこないんだよと
金って何のこともないんだと
あんた人間でしょうにと
人間が人間に対して何ができるのかいと
自分にできることは精一杯
自分の楽を置いといて
自分の贅沢を置いといて
自分にできる精一杯やれないと
それであなたは何のことなくこの世の中で生きているんだよと
豊かさというのはそれではないかと
いう場合もありますけど
どちらでもあまり受けませんね
はい そういうことで あの
私たちはこの好きなものがついてくると
随分喜んで 吾輩は幸せだとか恵まれているんだとかね
思うんだけど この欲しいものも
自分欲しいものでわかる
自分欲しい愛するものも
毎日毎日毎日消えて消えていくものな
変わって変わっていくものなんです
離れていくものなんです
それは事実です はい  5番目の項目
この砂時計で分かりませんね
カッマッソコウミカッマダーヤーどカッマヨーニカッマバンドゥカッマパティサラナ
これ長いんです 私は業によって作られ
業を相続する 業により生まれ
業の親族であり 業に依存しているのです
私は全部何もなく 単純に業のみだけあるという意味なんです
体の細胞一個一個も業なんですね
だって業によって作られているんだから
自分もらうもの 得るもの
相続するもの やっぱり自分のものでしょ
相続っていうのは業なんですね
これ続きですね  5番目の私は何かの行為をする
善または悪 その行為を相続するのであると常に観察するべきです
それ  5番目の箇条ですね
業によって作られて 業を相続する
業を親族にする 業に依存している
業によって生まれたものであると
で という私が何かやると
それは善であれ悪であれ
私が相続するんだよと
いうことで 業っていうのは行為なんですね
生きることは行為することでもあります
そういうことで こうやって結ばれるか
金の 何て言いますか ゴールデンキーもらうかどちらかなんですね
人生で これは自分の行為の結果なんです
手足縛られて何もできなくて
不幸の鈍足のうち行ったら
それは 自分の行為の結果
はい これで五ヶ条が終わりました
これは仏教徒なら暗記しなくちゃいけないんです
で 短い言葉で暗記したっても構いません
ビャーディダンモ あ ジャラダンモ
ビャーディダンモ マラナダンモという 3つですね
で それから 4番目は何でしたっけ？あのピエヒマナーピヒというものから離れなくちゃいけないんですね
で  5番目は業ですね 業の文章は長いんですよ
カンマッソコーミ カンマダーヤード
カンマユーニ カンマバント
カンマパティサラヌ ヤンガンマンカリッサーミ
カルヤーナンワーパーパカンワ
タッサーダーヤードバイッサーミって結構長い文章です
なんでこんなことを推薦しますかというと
無知により酔いを覚めましょうと
人間が酔っているんです
この酔うという言葉をお釈迦様は使っています
酔っ払いですね 酔いを覚めてほしいと
はい で まあ一というか
パートワンですね アッティビッカウェサッラーナンヨッバネヨッバナマド
これなかなかヨッバナマド
辞書を引かなかったんですから
適切な言葉は見つからないでしたけど
比丘たちよ 生命には若々しさに対する酔いがありますと
一応わかるでしょうね
若者っていうのはもう無鉄砲といった日本語の言葉がありますからね
なんか頭酔っちゃいますね
好き勝手なことをわがまま好き勝手な放題でやってますね
若い時はね まあ悪いことをするは
遊びはするわ それは良くないですよと言ったら聞かない
元気だからいいんじゃない？とかね
不倫するわ こんなのやめなさい
やっぱり元気だから別にいいんじゃない？という感じでしょ
あんまり酒の体に いえ
大丈夫 私の体はとかね
そういうことで 私はよく使っていた単語がありまして
この贅沢ボケという言葉
他の人々も使っているのを聞いてからやめました
それ初めて私が使った単語なんですよ
日本で で まあパクられちゃったんで
で あのボケという言葉はまあまあ冗談で使う単語ですけど
ボケよりは厳しいんですよ
この何か他の単語あればいいかなと思って
思い浮かばなかったんですね
で 贅沢ボケよりもなんかノリなんですね
乗ってるんです 若さに乗ってるんですね
そうするとちょっと危険なんですね
若々しさ ボケだったら別に
まあまあボケてるだけでね
もうそれほど危険がないんですね
これ乗りすぎちゃって
それからアーロゲ アーロゲマド
いわゆる健康に対する酔いがありますね
私は風邪一つ引いたことがないんだよとかね
今 80歳だけどね 病院に行ったことがないんだぞとかいう
80歳の人が言ったってもね
これは構いませんだけど
しかし その酔いがありますね
だからいいということを聞かないんですね
もう乱暴でわがままで
ジリジリとマド 生きていることに対して
また酔い 私たちは生きている間で堂々として生きてるんだから
まああれもやる これもやるとかね
あれしなかったら生きてる価値がないんだぞとかね
ずいぶん酔っちゃいますね
ピエスマナーピエスチャンドラゴ
これちょっと言葉違います
4番目 愛する者に対する愛着があります
執着ですね 骨董品で騙されて
江戸時代のものだと言って
どこかに作ったものも
もうまあ 20万円で買って
まあ本当はまあ 1,900円ですけどとかね
みんな掛け軸の場合 よくやりますからね
ほとんど 2,000円のもので
まあこれは 100万円ぐらい価値あります
なんかテレビ番組ありますね
何でも鑑定団っていう
で 自分がそうやってね
骨董品買っても愛するものでしょ
それにはすごい執着がありますね
昔に使って捨てたガラクタなんですけど
手袋で触るんですね だから愛着がありますよ
愛着があると本当に大変なことになります
5番目 なぜ業に依存していることを観察するのでしょうか？じゃあ 5番目
ちょっとわからないですよ
なんで私は業そのものであると観察しなくちゃいけないんですかね
私は何か喋っても それは業
何か人の話を聞いても
それは私の業 人からアメ玉 1個もらっても
それは私の業 昼ご飯におにぎりでも食べようかなと思ったら
おにぎり まあ 2つはもう多すぎだから
1個だけ買ってきて開けたところでボソッと滑っちゃう
もう食べられなくなっちゃうんですね
それでまたコンビニに行って買う時間がないんですね
それで勉強会に来なくちゃいけないんですね
お腹が空いたままで これも私の業ということにしなくちゃいけないんです
なぜなんで何でもかんでも業にするんでしょうかね
身行為で行う悪行為が存在するからです
世の中で悪行為があるんですよ
身口意っていうのは 体
言葉 考えるっていう 3つの行為なんですね
それで悪いことをするんですね
だから業本でいると悪いことをしないことになります
人間が業を観察しないんだから
平気で悪いことをして生きているんです
これが大きな問題なんです
世の中一向に良くならないんです
いくら法律があっても
いくら裁判を厳しくしても
世の中はうまくいかない
特にイスラムの国々では
法律はものえらく厳しいんですよ
ほんのちょっとしたことで死刑にするんですね
裁判も弁護士あれこれと弁護士の話を聞きません
イスラム教のイマーム誰かが証言すればいいんです
弁護士たちでイマームに逆らってと
新しい罪が加算されます
だから国際法律は効きません
シャリアというイスラム教の法律によって証言なし
もう有罪にする ただ すぐもうもう 1日2日でも人を処分して終わっちゃうんですね
そこまで厳しいんだったら
そういう国々で罪がないはずでしょうね
日本よりもいっぱいあります
現実は だから いくら裁判をあれやこれやと決めても
神が心そうと言っても意味がないんです
これ 直す方法というのは事実を見た方がいいんですね
だから業 人間に理解できない難しい話ですが
あのいくらかわかると思いますよ
自分をやったことの結果は自分の責任だと
それぐらいでも理解してほしい
私が喋ったことの責任は私が持たなくちゃいけない
私は人を侮辱して誹謗中傷して
で 隣の部屋にいる田中さんを訴えることできないでしょうに
やっぱり誹謗中傷した人が訴えられちゃいますね
だからそれぐらいは事実でしょうに
だから 業を自分が業であると知っている人が自然に悪行為をしないのです
はい そういうわけで 事実に目覚めるということをします １
若さによって 生命は体で言葉で考えることで悪行為をする
もう若さに まあ本当は正しい日本語で若さ
若々しさなんですけど
若々しさによって酔っ払っちゃって
生命は体で言葉で考えることで悪行為をするんです
老いるものだと いえ そうじゃなくて
本当は老いるものだ 私は知っていると
あの酔いは完全に覚める
または薄くなったりします
だから若者も まあ結局は毎日年取っているんだと
鏡で顔を見ながら 今は見た目はいいんだけど
何年持つものかと これはとかね
そうやって自分が老いるのだということを観察すると
酔えないんですね 冷静でいられます
ですから 酔いが完全に覚めるか
薄くなるかなんです  2番目
健康によって生命は体で
言葉で考えることで悪行為をする
病気になるのだと観察すると
あの酔いは完全に覚める
または薄くなったりする
吾輩は健康そのものやって酔ってしまうと何するかわからないんですね
やっぱり命は病気でできているんだと思っちゃうと大人しくなります
酔いが覚めます  3番目
生きていることによって
生命は体で 言葉で考えることで悪行為をする
必ず死ぬのだと観察すると
あの酔いは完全に覚める
または薄くなったりする
すごくお釈迦様が心理学的に教えていますよ
私たちは酔ってるんだと
酔っ払いだと この酔っ払いの良い状態が消す
精神的な心理学的なしっかりしたアドバイスをしているだけ
人は死ぬんだよと思っちゃうと
生きてることに対するジーヴィタマデですね
パーリ語でジーヴィタマダと酔いが消えちゃうんです
4番目 好きなものに対する愛着によって
生命は体で 言葉で 考えることで悪行為をしますね
欲しいものなら強盗でもして手に入りたいでしょうに
手に入れたいでしょうに
自分欲しい人に 自分好きな人に
誰かがちょっと一言葉かけただけでも腹が立って殴りに行くでしょうに
だから悪いことするんですよ
欲しいものはすぐ自分のものであると思っちゃうと
好きなものは必ず変わるのだ
離れていくのだと観察すると
あの酔いは完全に覚め
または薄くなったりします
それから命は悪から守られます
5番目 生命は体で悪行為をする
言葉で悪行為をする 考えることで悪行為をする
業に依存しているのだと観察すると
あの悪行為は冒せなくなる
または薄くなる 悪いことをできなくなっちゃうんです
あの人をもう嫌いだから
まあもう殺せと殺したいと思っても
やっぱりこの悪行為が結果
私が依存しなくちゃあかん
私は相続しなくちゃあかんやと
だったら相続するならば良いことを相続したいでしょうに
誰もね いくらお父さんのことを大好きであっても
お父さんがものすごい高い借金しているならば
同時に財産もあると 放棄しますね
財産相続の権利は 財産にいっぱいいろいろ借金がかかっているならばね
...ということは たとえ親の財産であっても
いいものを相続したいんです
悪いものは相続したくないんです
そこで日本の法律は まあ財産をあなたは相続するかしないかということは自由に決めてくださいと
しかし 借金は必ず払いなさいという不自然な法則なんです
親がお金借りたならば
もう親がない場合はもう子供が払わなくちゃいけないっていう風に
だから そこから逃げるためには
もう必ずしも親が借金しただけで子供が払う必要はないでしょうに
これ 家族の共通目的で
山分けして借金したならば
家族みんなに払う義務がありますけど
親が勝手に遊んで勝手にバカなことをやって
どこかで女を作って その女の人の機嫌を取るためにあちこちで借金してプレゼントあげたりしたならば
子供はその借金を払う必要はないでしょうに
しかし 法律ではまあ全部子供は払わなくちゃいけないんだと
財産の場合はそうじゃないんです
あんた子供でしょ 必ずこの親の財産もらいなさいとはないんです
もらうかもらわないかと
もう参加していないで決めてくださいと
いう なんかへんてこりんな法律ですね
はい ここで私たちは喋ったらその結果が自分に来る
考えたらこの結果が自分に来る
体を動かしたらその結果が自分に来るとわかったならば
悪いことは自然にやめちゃいますよ
これが悪行をやめる一番いい方法なんです
一番理性的で精神的に微塵も問題を起こらない方法なんですね
何も理解しないで嘘を言ってはいけませんよと言ったところで
嘘を言わないように頑張るとストレス溜まるんでしょうに
何も説得させないで お釈迦様おっしゃったんだから
お坊さんが言うんだからね
酒飲むなよと よくわかりました
酒飲まないことにすると思っても
飲みたい人にとってはものすごい苦しいんです
それが だから世の中で法律は破るためにあるという言葉があるでしょ
同じく戒律も破るためにあるんですね
誰でもいかにして戒律を破るのかということばっかり考えているんです
それっていうのは もう理解していないって意味なんですね
仏教全体に酒飲んではいけないんです
酒も酒も なのに日本の仏教では酒を飲めなかったらいい坊主ではありませんと
だから尊敬される坊主になるために
日本では酒を飲まなくちゃいけないんですね
それを聞いたところで
ああ 日本で生まれなかったことをよかったなと私は思ったんですね
日本に生まれたならば
あんな気持ち悪いものを飲む羽目になるんだと
酒ってどんな味かと 私はいろんな人に正直に聞いたことあるんですね
とにかく自分の国の若者に聞いたんですね
大学の一緒に仕事をしていた仲間もいます
います みんな結構酒飲むんですね
で 言ったらもうまあ これはこんな味で
これはこんな味でとかね
よく明確に まあ学者ですからね
よくわかりやすく説明してくれるんですよ
なんかね 水割りでもしなかったらね
やけどするような感じがするんだと
口の中から喉からもう全部お腹に入った時からもね
それから科学的に見ても
アルコールっていうのはものすごい怖いもんなんです
もうすぐたちまち死ぬんです
純粋なアルコールだったら
であのありますよ いる研究室なんかで九十九パーセントのアルコールとかはね
研究のために あんなのはもう
大変です ただちょっと体に入っただけでも
もう血液にさっと吸収吸収するんです
触れただけでも で 危ない
で じゃあ話が脱線しますから
また元に戻ります あんまり遠く脱線する前に元に戻さないと
まあ例えばね 酒飲んではいけないということは戒律だよと言うと
日本の方々の場合は 日本文化っていうのは酒文化ですからね
毎日の行事 あれやこれや全部しきたりとかね
まあ酒で成り立っているでしょうね
ビールも皆様飲むでしょうね
ビールは一種類しか飲まないんですね
いろんな種類ありますけど
いろいろ店に行ったところで話を聞くんですね
店に入った途端 とりあえずビールというものを注文するんです
どこでも まず じゃあとりあえずビール
はい わかりましたと もう店の人はビール１本持ってくるんですね
私は考えてもアサヒビールもあるし
サントリーもあるし キリンもあるし
なんでとりあえずビールばっかり飲むんですかと
だからそこを言ったって
私は日本語がわからないと思われますから
あまり言わないんですね
私は別な意味で思ってますけどね
で みんなとりあえずビール飲んで
なんで飲むのかというと
それが当たり前で決まっていて
なんでその意味なんです
人ならもう注文する前にビール飲むものであると
それからゆっくりとメニューを調べればいいんです
だからあれがもうもう固定している注文なんです
ですから サントリーであろうがキリンであろうか
もうとりあえずビールになるんです
だからそこを知った上で
私は冗談言って なんであんたキリンビール飲まないんですか？あれまずいんですか？と
なぜサントリービール飲まないんですか？とかね
聞きたいんですけど そうするとあんた日本語わからないでしょって言われるでしょうね
じゃあそこはやめます
そういうことで 我々のすべての行為が自分が創作するんだよとわかると
やばいと思っちゃう 自動的に
部屋で一人でいる時でも
ちょっと外へ出たところで
自動販売機で酒を売ってあっても
今あるかどうか分かりませんだけど
前はどこでもカップ酒っていうのは自動販売機で売ってましたからね
最近ちょっと見当たらいないんですね
で だから一人で部屋に住んでいる人も
ドアを開けて外へ出たら
そこで自動販売機でカップ酒を売っていても
飲む気にはなれませんね
自分の行為の結果は自分で創作しますからということで
そういうことで すごく気楽に完璧に道徳守られます
悪をやめられます そのために
なんでこれが？なんでこれが入ったんですかね
あ もう時間 もうちょっと休憩にした方がいいみたい
はい ちょっと休憩いたしまして
知恵の扉を叩きましょう
では始まります あの ちょっと訂正がございます
今教えていただきましたけど
あの借金 相続の場合はね
今の日本の法律では あの
まあまあ 放棄できますと
借金も安心してください
で そういうことで 10分ぐらい喋ったものは無駄になってしまったと
で プラスもマイナスも両方
親の財産をね 放棄したければ放棄できますということで
しかし 保証人になったらまあ全く断言的に無理
これ親戚でなくてもね
怖いんです で はい 今日あの次
あの経典の一番最初の最後のところ
智慧の扉を叩くという解脱に達する道が開く
この 5つの項目を何もやることないんです
それはただ単に妄想する代わりに
この 5つを考えればいいんです
あの 私はパーリ語で覚えてくださいと言ったってもね
それは私たちやるべきものであって
皆様は自分なりに日本訳にして頭で考えればいいんです
毎日年取っているものやとかね
まあやっぱり何やっても必ず死ぬんだとかね
そういう風に考えるだけなんです
どうってことないんです
そういうもんやりやすい
全部剛で剛でできているんだとかね
好きなものはいっぱいあるんだけどね
家族やら子供やらいろいろ
でもみんな変わっていきますよと
出ていきますよと そう考えるだけなんです
そう考えてみると びっくりすることが起こるんです
はい 次のセクション このびっくりすることが起こるのはこの場合なんです
私だけ老いるではありません
老いるのではありません
生命といえるすべてが老いる性質なのです
次のステップでそれも考えるんです
これ お釈迦様は厳しく強調するんです
原文がスライドでないんだから読みます
はい ネコアハンエーコジャラダンモ
アハンエーはエーコ 私一人だけ年取るわけじゃないんだと
アタコヤーワタサッターナンアーガティ
生命と言うべきものはあるならば
そこすべて 命たるものはすべて
えっと ガティチュティウパパアクティ
もう徹底的に提起するんです
いわゆる他宗教のことを入れて
考えちゃうと みんな絶対的神だと思っているものもいないんだけど
万が一いたならばね それもまとめて含めて生命たるものはすべてというんです
誰でも老いるんだと で
パーリ語でサッベーサッタ
一切衆生はという風になるんですね
サッベーサッタ ジャラダンマ
ジャラン アナティタ すべての生命が老いるものである
老いは超えてないんだと
このように常に観察すると道が現れるんですね
私が老いる性質だなとか思うだけじゃなくて
生命なら誰でも一人のカラス
一切生命が老いるんだよと言うと
かなりスケール大きく観察することになるんです
これは全部いきます 道が現れるということは
マッゴーサンジャーヤティなんですね
サンジャーヤティっていうのは
自分でひらめいてくる
見えてくる あ 生き方 これだと見えてくるんですね
そこでその道を歩むことになります
あの 1項目しか説明してないんだけど
5項目にも入ります 死ぬのは私だけじゃなくて
生命たるすべて死にます
サッベーサッタ マラナダンマ
マラナン アナティタと
で それから好きなものに執着する
それはすべての生命同じだと
そういう感じで この道
その道を これ自分にわかってきた生き方のことですね
道っていうのは 生命ならみんな年取るんだ
生命ならみんな死ぬんだ
生命ならみんなね 好きなものに執着するんだと
生命ならみんなね みんな好きなものから離れていかなくちゃいけないんだと
生命ならみんな業によって作られているんだと
そういうふうに考えるんですね
そうすると 自分だけじゃなくて
一切生命が同じ法則に管理されていることは見えてくるんですね
それで ではどうやればいいんですかと
私はどんな生き方すればいいのかい？と言うと
すぐ道が あ こんな道だと見えてくるんです
それははっきり言えば八正道なんですね
正見 正思惟 正語 正語 正命という正しい生き方というのは見えてくるんですね
その生き方で生きてみるんですね
だから自分にもいろんなものできなくなったでしょ
そこでできる生き方はこれだと見えてきたんだから
それで生きてみるんです
それで煩悩がすべてなくなるんです
それだけじゃない 潜在煩悩までなくなります
潜在煩悩っていうのは今はないが
もしかすると現れるかもしれません
例えば 私たちは未だこの世で生まれてからはね
人を殺したことがないんでしょ
しかし 怒りがありますね
だから もし条件が揃ったところで殺してしまう可能性はあります
だから潜在煩悩っていうのは
今はない もしかすると現れる
このもしかすると現れる煩悩まで消えてしまいます
サンヨウジャナニ サッバスパヒアンティ
アヌセヤー ビャンティ
ホンティ このアヌセヤーという
これは潜在煩悩ですね
サンヨウジャナっていうのは束縛っていう意味なんですね
まあ全部煩悩にしちゃったんです
はい これでまあ仏教はとても簡単に心の進化を語っています
この 5つの過程を普遍的な事実として観察する
酔いから覚めるのです
するとですけどね すると酔いから覚めるのです
存在に対する見方が変わるんですね
今まで皆様の頭にあった命って何や？とかね
日本人って何や？とかね
外国人って何や？とかね
いろんな考えがあったでしょう
すべて消えます 全く違う見方が見えてくるんです
生命というふうに見られるようになります
それぐらいはすごい進化でしょ
普通の進化では 自分のことしかいまだに我々の脳細胞には考えることができないんです
あの進化の過程で人間になってからまだ時間経ってないんですね
ずいぶん最近ですね 人間が現れたのは
だから人間が現れてから
人間の脳が開発する時間がまだ足らないみたい
だからそこをまた 1万年
4万年待つと もう人間いないかもしれませんし
それより先にお互いの憎しみ
怒りでね 殺し合いやってるし
今もなんか将来すごい危険な状態になってるでしょうに
だから早くも進化しなくちゃいけないんですね
この方法で進化しますね
何を目指してどう生きるべきかという道を発見して
それを実践して解脱に達するんです
こんな五箇条を考えるだけ
難しい修行じゃないんです
余計な無駄なことをいっぱい考えてるでしょうに
その時間でこの五箇条を考えているんです
それですごい進化が起こるんです
あ 終わったんですね あっという間に
で これパーリ語ではね
あの 芸にしてるんですね
覚えてもらいたくて ビャーディダンマジャラダンマアトーマルナダンミノ
ヤタダンマタタサッタジグッチャンティプトゥジャナ
それは老いる 老いる性質
病の性質 老いる性質 それから死性質
これは法則であると すべての生命に対する
しかし ジグッチャンティプトゥジャナ
一般人がその話は嫌やと思っちゃいますよ
まあ気持ち悪いと思いますよと
気持ち悪い話やと とんでもない話やと
聞きたくないやという愚か者はそう思いますよと
アハンチェタンジグッチェイアンエワンダンメスパニスーナメタンパティルーパッサーパティルーパッサーママエワンヴィハリノー
もし私もこの一般人と一緒に
あ 嫌だ こんな話はと思っちゃうと
けしからんやと これが真理だと
真理は気持ち悪いと思ってはあかんやと
事実ですから こういう
いわゆる何といいますか
理性のある人間でそうして生きてみようと思う
する私が一般人が嫌いだから俺も嫌いだよって言ったらね
事実に背くことになりますよ
だから私はやりませんよと
次の偈 ソーエワンヴィハラントーニャッターダンマンニルーパディンアーローゲヨッバナスミンチャジービタスミンチャイエマダ
そのように思った人が
そのように考えるならば
ニルーパディ束縛がなくなりますよ
こんなどうでもいいことにする束縛はなくなります
それから健康に対する
また若さ 若々しさに対する
また命に対する酔いが
これなくなりますよと
サッベーマデーアビ アビボースミーネッカマンダットケーマト
それで私はすべての酔いから目が覚めて
ネッカマン この死ぬものから離れましょうと
老いるものから離れましょうと
病になるものから離れましょうと
関わり持たないということは
離欲というか 厭離というんですね
ネッカマですね その心が生まれてくるんだと
解脱の心 タッセメアウッサーホーニッバーナアビバッサト
ですから 解脱しようではないかというすごいこのやる気が私に生まれてくるんだと
一般人と違うやる気が生まれてくるんです
ナハンバッボエタラヒカマニパティセウィトゥンアニワッテティバヴィッサーミブラフマチャリアパラヤノという最後の偈
そういう私が一般人と同じくこの溺れて生活することは私にはもうできませんと
不可能になりましたと
私は戻りませんよと もう落ちませんよと
涅槃に修行の最後の結果である涅槃に達していますよというふうな偈で
そこを最終的には終わっています
はい そういうことで あの
老いること 病になること
死ぬこと それから好きなものから好きなものはすべて変化して変わっていくこと
それから我々はすべて業によってできているんだと
その五箇所 考えてみると
頭の中で心が清らかになって解脱に達しますという教典なんです
そういうことで 話はそこら辺で終了します
ちょっと早く喋ってましたけど
時間間に合わないと思うので
まあ見事に早く終わりましたので
これから皆様の質問の時間にいたします
ありがとうございます
私の身近なところで歳代の女性
この人は多分アルツハイマーだと思います
で 体とかですね いろんなことによって悩んでいるんですけども
まさにあの 年を取りたくない
死にたくない 健康でいたい
いろんな好きなものがですね
いろいろあるんですけども
そういうものもいろいろ欲しいと
そういう状況で生きていくという感じです
こういう人はですね 生きていてですけども
あんまり生きる希望がないような感じで生きていて
で そういうものをですね
掴むことなくしょうがないという話をしてもですね
本人としてはもう体が苦しくて
いろんなやりたいことができなくて
苦しくてたまらないと
そういう状況で生きているんですね
で この後もしょうないと
まあ言ってもですね そのものはあの
私の説得ぐらいではなかなか納得するような
そんな感じではないんですね
自分でも今のような話がですね
できるわけでもないのに
教えてあげて そういうふうな力もちょっとないかなと思うんですけど
なんとかしてあげたいなと
あんまりそう長い命じゃないかもしれないですね
そういう時に 他の私の叔父たちもそうでしたけども
死にたくないというのを繰り返しながらですね
死んでいくと そういう状況にはちょっとしたくはないなというふうに思うんですけども
これってどうしたらいいのかなということをちょっともしもし
願いであればちょっとお聞かせ
うん だから人は最後だからね
言うことはもう堂々と厳しく言った方がいい場合もあります
それは人の性格を見て判断しなくちゃいけないんですけどね
で まず質問すればいいんじゃないですか
死にたくないの？と ということは
まだ生きていて何したいんですか？と
じゃあおばあちゃんが生きていたら
まあまあ 他の人々とパクパクとごちそうを食べられますかと
山の登ったり スキーやったり
外国旅行したり お化粧したり
ブランドの服を着たりとかね
できますかと 生きていたても結局そのまんまでしょうにと
家で 何もできなくて テレビばっかり見ながら
それで だから何をやりたいんですかと
できなかったことは何なのかと
やりたいことは何なのかと
はっきり聞いてみてください
まず 全部言ってくださいと
これもやりたかった これもやりたかった
これもやりたかった そこでできたら
まあ生きていたってもこれは無理でしょうと
生きていたてもこれは無理でしょうと
これは無理でしょうと
まあうなぎ食べたかったら
明日持ってきますよと
でも食えないで それもお医者さんがね
食べられない状態だったら
それは丸でしょうにと
バスでしょうにと だったらできることは今は寝たきりで
ベッドでいくことで やっぱり私もね
このままで 100年ぐらいいてほしいと思ってますよと
言うと腹が立ってくる可能性あります
それ一つのやり方 攻撃の仕方なんですね
もう一つ あなたのもの
今まで人生でね あなたのものになったのは何ですかと
若い時はね お母さんがいて
お父さんがいて 今いるんですかと
家がやって で それから結婚して
私の旦那 私の家族と今いるんですかと
今あなたの体に残っている私のものって何ですかと
結局は何もないでしょうにと
例えば最後にいろいろ薬もらったり
もう点滴すらこれってあなたのものじゃないでしょうにと
若い時買った高い幸福服とかね
今ボロボロでしょうにと
そのまま保管してあったっても使えないでしょうにと
だからあなたのものって何もないんだと
だから何か自分のものっていうものを作ったらどうですかと
それだったら生きていたって意味がありますよと
自分のものというのは
自分で楽しみ 喜びを感じることではないかと
どこへ行ったって心を持っていくでしょうにと
だから自分のものは何もないんだっていうことを説得する
それも一つの方法ですね
だから次 まあ死にたくないわ
あれもやりたい これもやりたいと思うたびに苦しいでしょうにと
いくら死にたくないと言ったっても死にますよと
苦しくて汚い醜い心で死んじゃったらね
知ったことじゃないんだと
心に楽しみがなければ
1 日でも生きる意味がないでしょうにと
悔しくて 嫉妬深くて 恨みでなんで 1 日でも生きているんですかね
例えば ものすごい優しい心でね
明るい心で まあみんな一生懸命面倒を見てみるし
いるし みんな本当に親切ないい人々に囲まれてね
やっぱり君たちがいるんだからね
毎日楽しいんだよと だから死ぬのは惜しいなという場合は
そちらに喜びがありますからね
そこもないならばね だからそこが最後のポイントなんですけど
苦しんで悩んで 憎しみ
怒り 嫉妬 わがままで汚れた心でね
1日でも生きることは苦しいんだと
それでも死にたくなければ
もうそうやってとことん苦しんで長生きしてくださいと
応援しますと もっと苦しくなることを言いますと
そうするともう生きる気が出てきますからね
長生きできますよというふうな
すごい厳しい態度で言わなくちゃいけないんですね
まああの どうしても馬鹿だったらね
まあそんなこと置いといてね
楽しくいきましょうよと
全くも見込みない 知恵のひとかけらもないんだったらね
まあまあそんなこと言ったってもね
まあもう死にたくない
あれこれ私も思いますけど
まあ病気になりたくないと思ったってもなっちゃうわ
まあまあ これは成り行きだからね
そんなのは気にしないで楽しくいきましょうよと
みかんでも食べて 今日花も
これも綺麗でしょうとかね
で まあもう楽しく毎日ね
過ごしましょうよと 明日なんのことわかりませんだからね
という感じで もう優しく
これはもう最後の手段で
知恵がひとかけらもない場合は
そういうふうにするしかないんですね
とにかく まあ私たちは知り合いだから
知ってる人だからね 親戚だから心配して悩みますが
生きるってこと 残酷なものなんですね
その方が自分の行為で生きているんでしょうね
だから まあどうすることもできない
自分の身くいのね 考えることによって
まあ次の人生は形成してしまいます
それが理性のある人から見ればやばいんですが
本人が気づかなかったらね
聞こうという耳を持たなかったら
もう しょうがない で 龍がね
そうやって完璧に嘘の世界で生きてきたでしょうに
世界は私たちをマインドコントロールで騙されているんですけど
個人個人でもわざわざとそこでもうもうパクリすぎちゃって
このインチキ世界にもう乗ってしまって
もうとことん自分でも自己マインドコントロールする
そういう人々なんですね
よく結構苦しんで死ぬのは
普通はもう誰でもね 社会から嘘を言われて
言われて 言われてね まあ頭がイカれていますけど
時々そんなこと言ったってそうじゃないでしょうとわかりますね
例えばお世辞でああ もう本当に年わかりませんね
まあなんか 40歳ぐらいですねとか言われたっても
あ そうかいと言いながら
心の中でそんなことあるわけないでしょうとかね
このアホやとかね いう気分でいる場合は
やっぱりどこかで自分が本当のことも知っている
生きることは苦しいんだから
人間っていうのは本当に自己暗示かけるんです
で 例えばね 自分がまあまあ 65歳
70歳と で 年は知ってますけど
まあでもまだまだ元気ですからね
まだまだ大丈夫です もうちょっと運動でもすればまだ元気になるんじゃない？とかね
というふうに自己暗示かけるんですね
死ぬのは先のことやとかね
ということで 人間はもう自己暗示かけたりはする
まあ死にたくないという人っていうのは
みんなやばいんですよ
だから死ねない状態にいるんですね
いいことを何もしていないんですね
人生に満足せていないんです
だから死にたくない人っていうのは大失敗者なんですね
そこを教えたってもいいんですね
死にたくないっていうのは
あなたの人生っていうのはね
何も 喜ぶことはなかったでしょうにと
生きていて良かったというようなことって一つもないでしょうにと
で そこを教えてあげて
やっぱり人間っていうのはね
馬鹿でいるわけでもないんだから
それなりに頑張ってますから
逆にね 人間としてあんたもしっかりやってきたでしょうにと
子供を育てたり 家を守ったり
そうやってこの国にいろいろ貢献して
まあ結構頑張っていたでしょうにと
だからそこはまあよく頑張りましたと
よく頑張って生きてきましたっていうことを次に教えてあげなくちゃいけない
これ順番があります いう場合は
だからこの最後の人に案内することは結構難しいんです
まあ頑張ってみてください
できる範囲で はい  いや
他のパターンだったのか
ちょっとまだ言うことが全くまとまらないですけど
今の方のようにお年寄りに対して
お年寄りに少しものアルツハイマーなんかも出てきてしまったようなお年寄りに対して
どういうふうに接してあげたらよろしいでしょうかということで
私もやっぱり長老の声
おっしゃったようなこととか
あと本にここに書いてあるようなことなんかが理解できるような能力があればいいですけども
やはり脳の機能の低下ということがありますので
なかなかそういうことを理解する力もだんだん衰えてくるという状況もあると思います
それでもしお年寄りに限らず
子供にも障害のある子供とか
そういう子供もいますので
そういう時に脳の機能の低下を何か心の力で補うというか
それによって知恵が現れてくるような
そういうふうな方法というのは方法っていうのもあれですけど
はいはい あの脳の機能低下するとね
まあ我々人間というのは脳で喋ったりしますからね
唯一なね 我々の道具がね
壊れるとすごく一番悲しい病気はそれなんですね
私の主観で言えばね がんとかなんとかとかね
もう手足切断することになるとかね
どうってことないんです
がんになっても人間としてプライドを持って生きていられるしね
アルツハイマーとかになってくると
そこまでなくなりますから
体健康やってたってもね
それ悲しいんですよ で
まだまあ一応生まれつきね
脳の機能に問題ある子供たちも生まれてくるし
で だから救いのポイントはこちらにあるんですね
じゃあ脳がうまくいかなくても
人間には感情っていうものあるんですね
で 感情は悪意 悪いものも良いものもありますね
そこは失いません 知識はあるない
どっちでもいいんです
関係ないんです 本当は感情っていうのは動物にもあって
人間にもあって これはもう死ぬ瞬間まであるんですね
感情っていうのは仏教
煩悩と言いますけど 煩悩なら悪いに決まってますけどね
いい感情もありますね
ニコッと笑うとかね 優しくなるとかね
例えばまあこれ例えば話で
もう本当にアルツハイマーのおばあちゃんがいるとしましょう
それで可愛い猫 でも持っていて
可愛いですねとかね うん
可愛いですと言うでしょうね
同時に ああ もうあの人も可愛いですねとかね
ああ この人も可愛いですねとかね
そういうふうに この可愛いっていうことは
ある面では欲かもしれませんだけど
やっぱり優しさも入ってるでしょ
そういうことはダラダラダラダラと言ってあげて
この感情を明るくするんですね
喋っても意味がないんですよ
論理的には よく日本人よくやります
良かったですねとかね
例えば子供があまりも知恵が能力がなくて
何も言えないんですけど
何か誰か持ってきたら
ご飯持ってきたら 自分でね
ありがとうね 美味しいですねとかね
良かったね 一生懸命美味しく作ってくれてとかね
そういうふうなことを言えばいいんです
そうすると自分が強引にこの優しい感情をかき立てる
感情には反応する あの
決してそういう人々は怒るようなことはしてはいけない
その人々はやっていることには自分たちが怒る可能性はよくありますけどね
特にアルツハイマーの場合は
あの脳が壊れてもある位置で止まるんです
その位置を発見するんですよ
80歳のおばあちゃんであっても
もしかすると 40歳のところで落ちて落ちて落ちて止まることもあります
時々まだ落ちちゃって
細胞が脳細胞がね 子供に戻ることもありますね
そのその年齢を発見してほしいんです
アルツハイマーになった人が
今 脳がどんな年齢まで下がっているのかと
それに合わせて本気で付き合えばいいんです
いろいろ聞いた話で 20歳に落ちてしまったこともあったりとかね
なぜかというと 結婚してからの人生はすごく苦しかった
うまくいかなかった 不安だらけで
しかしなんか 20歳頃は
お母さんも優しくて お父さんも優しくて
なんとなく気分が良かったと
その気分が良かったというところで
その脳は壊れなくなっちゃうんですね
そこで年は 85歳ですけど
おばあちゃんが自分が 20歳だと思ってますね
未婚だと思ってるんですね
それに直してはいけません
自分に子供もないと孫もないと思っているんですね
でも現実は子供いて孫もいるんですよ
しかし それ思い出す必要はないんです
まったく 20歳の時と同じく接すればいいんです
それで知らないこと おばあちゃんに聞いた方がいいんですね
聞いたら何々さんどうですか？まあ
元気でいますよとかね
新しく友達作りましょうよとかね
言って 自分を紹介してあげて
自分の息子を娘を紹介してあげて
この人もすごくいい人ですよとかね
名前はなになにさんという自分の息子かもしれませんよ
だから本人がもう 20歳ですから
精神的にも息子はいないんですね
だからといって息子を面倒見なくちゃいけないでしょうね
だから紹介してあげる
だからおばあちゃんが当たりになっちゃったら
おばあちゃんと言ってはいけない
なになにちゃんと言わなくちゃいけない
なになにちゃん いい人を紹介してあげますよ
いい友達になりますよとか言って
息子を紹介してあげる
孫を紹介してあげる この人はいい人だからこれ頼みましょうかねとかね
この人にご飯持ってくるように頼みましょうかねとかね
というと ああ そうですねというと頼むんです
だからそこはあの なんて言いますか
感情のコミュニケーションですね
だからこの知識のコミュニケーションは不可能
で 私も知っているこの子供たちいますよ
脳のすごい重度で やっぱり周りがすごく優しくて
ニコニコでああ良かったねとかね
美味しいねとかね 強引に言ったりして
ああ 楽しいとかね 本人は言えません
こちら言うんですね そうするとこの優しい感情に乗るんです
これが動物にさえもありますから
心配しないでください
それだけです あのコミュニケーションの手段は
それでやると勘弁する人々も楽です
この大体あの認知障害の人々の面倒を見ることというのはすごく疲れるでしょ
ものすごく疲れる理由が
あの頭を使っているだからなんです
だから私たちは 知識人はもう頭を使いますけど
知識人同士で相手に対してはまあ感情だけで
例が悪いですが 言います
我々は犬の面倒を見て一度も疲れたことないでしょ
猫の面倒見と一度も疲れたことないでしょ
犬猫が病気になっても
まあ面倒見てあげる 動かなくなっても全部面倒見てあげる
そのまま排便したっても
全部処理してあげて 綺麗にしてあげて
ああ よかったよかったと自分勝手に言って
疲れませんね ストレスたまりませんね
なぜかというと 犬猫とはもう知識で関係コミュニケーションできないということを初めから知ってるんですね
愛情ではできますからね
それでできます 人間にしたって同じこと
脳が壊れたら まあ感情しか残ってないんです
感情は壊れないんですよ
だから あのある人の話なんですけど
で 随分立派な知識人で
社会人で もう立派に生きていたんですけど
もう最後になってくると脳が壊れちゃって
突然恐ろしく凶暴になりましたと
ものすごいもう殺人鬼みたいな精神がイカれちゃって凶暴になってしまったと
え？どういうことかとね
私に聞かれたっても 問題はやっぱりこれが悲しいんだけど
感情は残る だから動物も怒りやら嫉妬やら憎しみやら
そういう悪い感情はへっちゃらで持っちゃいますね
だから人間も悪い感情というのはへっちゃらで持ち続けるんです
で 感情は煩悩であり 業であり
悪行為でもありますが
そこで優しい感情を作ります
で 私が知っている犬たちの中で
この激しくわがままで
ライバル意識があって
餌なんかもらったところですごい凶暴になって
人間にも噛みつく 普段優しいんだけど
餌食べてるとか 誰も近寄れない
もう吠えて噛みつく 私はこれは直せないのかと
思って たった一日 二日かな
何も治りました そこで私はみんなに見せるんですね
じゃあ誰かご飯をあげてください
ご飯あげた あげてさっさとご飯あげる前はもうじゃれてじゃれていますよ
ご飯もらう瞬間でも吠えて噛みつくんですね
あんたご飯あげてくれ
私は取って見せますよ
私はいろいろ あんた一人勝手でご飯食べて
これ私にください 私は食べますから
取りますね 皿ごとに取ったら
何のことで私の顔を見て尾っぽ振りながら笑ってるんですね
どうだいと だからそこで私は何やったかというと
この別な優しさという感情をね
教えてあげたんですね
それであのワンちゃんが
まあこれただ遊んでるだけやと
私のこと可愛いんだからこんなことやってるんだとも知ってるんですね
人が違ったら噛み付くんだけど
それで私は堂々とご飯が入ってる皿回ることにとっても
もう何のこともなくもう笑っちゃうっていうか
おっぽふったりして そういうわけであの人を助けるのはそちらにあります
知識がなくなっても 脳が壊れても感情が残ります
そこで悪感情の代わりにズルズルと良い感情を我々は植えてあげるんです
植えてあげると 看病する私たちにも楽
相手がかわいくなってしまうんですね
で 認知障害になっているおばさんとおじさんとね
もうわけもわからないへんてこりんなことを喋ることが楽しくなっちゃうんですね
支離滅裂なこと で そういうことで
まあ感情でなんとかやってみて
やってみることですね
残っているのは 仏教はものすごい厳しい理屈ですから
それはちょっと実行できません
その代わりに仏教はね
慈しみと優しさとかね
憐れみの気持ちとかね
慈悲の瞑想を教えてあげてますからね
それには知識は要りません
はい 解決する方法はそういう方法だと思います
はい  他にいらっしゃいます
挙手していただければ
まずお願いします  あの
両親が結構小さい頃から結構自分としては期待に応えてきたつもりだったんですけど
今今時点でもなんかこう
まだ期待があるようで
なんかあんまりうまくいかないというか
あんまり好きになれないというか
結構頑張ってきたのになっていつもすごい思っちゃって
ちょっとあんまりうまくいかなくて
優しくちょっと顔を見せてくれませんか？ はい
うんうん  あの あんまり優しく接することができなくて
今日のお話とかも聞いてて
ちょっと両親に対して優しくできないのはすごい悪業なのかなっていうのでもあって
ちょっとどうしたらいいのかなって
ちょっとお聞きしたいんですけども
あんたね 前からもう本当は問題がありましてね
この両親に対してすごい憎しみを持ってるんでしょうね
これが法律違反でしょうね
だからこの言ってることは言い訳なんですね
両親の期待に まあなかなか叶うことはできなかったと
これってみんなのことなんですよ
ほとんどのお父さんとお母さんたち聞いたらね
自分の息子娘がね 全然自分たちが期待しているようにやってないというのは当たり前なんです
あんた特別と思うのは何やと
それは これとんでもない親ですよね
両親の期待に応えた子供っていうのはいるわけないでしょ
この世の中で みんなそれでも仲良くやってますよ
親から見ればまあどんでもないやつらですけどね
いいよく勉強して欲しかったんですけど
勉強しなかったとかね
立派ないい仕事を見つけて欲しかったんですけど
もうどうでもいい仕事です
ちょっと昨日聞いたいい人と一緒になって欲しかったんですけど
とんでもない人と一緒になったとかね
まあ期待外れと言えばもう次から次へと期待外れですね
親から見れば それでも自分の娘やと
自分の息子やと うちの子やと
そこ愛嬌あるんです 子供たちも子供たちで
お父さんのお母さんの話には期待のは一つも叶えてあげなかったのに
まあ甘えること これが普通です
だからあなたももう両親の期待にそぐわなかったってことっていうのは
もうよう関係ないんですね
だから両親に対するこの怒りっていうのはすごい罪なんですよ
自分が罪を犯してるんですね
だから自分の子は自分を相続するんだから
親と仲良くできなくなっちゃってるんですね
いまだに親が仲良くしたいと思っていると思いますよ
いまだに親がね お母さんがありがとうとかね
という一言が聞きたくなっていると思いますよ
ごく普通にダラダラダラダラと喋ってほしいんですよ
子供が 親がそれを期待しているんです
いくら出来の悪い子供であっても
あれやこれやとかね いい加減なことをよ
ダラダラダラダラ言うと
両親すごく喜ぶんです
だから私の答えはね 親の期待に応じる応じた子供っていうのはいません
じゃあ仏教の話ですから
お釈迦様っていうのは
人類の中で現れた完璧な完全な人格でしょ
微塵も間違いはないんです
電子顕微鏡でお釈迦様の人格を調べたっても
間違いはゼロなんです
では 親の期待に応えたんですかね
ないんです お父さんがまあ王様になって国を治めて欲しかったんです
いろいろ工夫したんですよ
家出しないようにと 当時インドでこの宮殿を 3つ作ったっていうことはね
相当苦労したでしょう
お父さんが それってまだ宮殿 2つ今ありますよ
インドに一つインドで
一つはネパールに もう一つあると思いますよ
まだ発見してないだけで
そこまでね お城 3つも作って
お前もうもう一年中こちらこちらこちらでもうそこに生活してくださいと
で 親の期待はたった一つ
あの国を跡継ぎに 国の跡継ぎになってください
それだけ それがやらなかったでしょうに
あれほど頑張ったのに
家出しましたし しかし
親子関係切れたというと
そうじゃないんです あのお父さんが 6年間も苦行をしている息子の話をね
あちこち調べるんですね
それでも 調べると自分が決めた道で頑張っているんですね
これで親として楽しいんですよ
うちの子はね 決めたことは
自分決めたことはもう私たちの話聞きませんと
しかし 自分決めたことはしっかりやっているんだと
で 本人が決めた道だからね
邪魔する必要はないんだと思うんですね
だから親がどれほど悲しかったでしょうかね
でもやっぱりすごく親孝行なんですね
そこで一旦悟ってから
お父さんに顔を見せるのは普通でしょうね
お釈迦様は行かないんですね
これまた失礼なこと 派手に弟子たちも作って
もう王様やらみんな仏教徒になっちゃって
もう派手に もう宣伝 宣伝じゃなくて伝道活動しているんですね
そこでもうスッドーデの王のもう情報資源いっぱいありまして
ネットワークを作ってやったんです
ただ 息子のために 国は小さかったんですけど
すごい小さい しかし たった一人の息子のためにあっちこっちネットワーク入れてあって
もう知っていたんですね
成功しているんだと それでお父さんが人々を送るんですよ
南の方に すごい長い道を歩いて歩いて
一度顔を見せてくださいと
ただそれだけ それで一つのグループが来たら
お釈迦様はあんまりもう派手にもう説法し
伝道説法しているんだからと説法を聞いてびっくりしちゃって
そのまま出家するんですね
出家したところで阿羅漢にもなったりするでしょう
あ 出家は再婚のメッセージを持って行ってはいけないんですね
もう再婚と関係ないとは言わないんですね
またグループ一つ また金を集めてもっともうグループ一つ作るんですね
そこをまた出家しちゃう
最後に何かでしたっけ？ナギタでしたっけ
名前は覚えてないんですけど
まあお釈迦様と一緒に遊んでいた同じ年の友達みたいにいた人で
もう最後にあなたに頼むしかないんだよとお父さん言うんですね
あんた仲良しでしょうにと
言いなさいよと あのシッダールタに
親に顔を見せてくださいと
言ったら その人がまあじゃあ私は言いますよと
しかし約束してくださいと
私は行ったらあのブッダのところに出家しますよと
許可してほしいんだと
どれほど息子のことを大事にするかというと
この送った人ももうもう次の王家を相続する人なんですね
だから何人か予備がいっぱいいるんです
王になる だからそれ一人亡くなるのはすごい損ですけど
まあ息子の顔を見ることできれば大丈夫やということで許可するんですね
それでその人が出家して
また修行して 時期を見てお釈迦様に報告するんですね
それはスッタニパータに
全部どのように語ったかということは
美しい芸にしてね 残ってますけどね
あのお坊さんがやっぱりまあ長老ですね
北の方ってとても美しいんだよと
環境も良くて 花がいっぱい咲いてという風に
この国をね まあ普通の国の美しさとか
あれやこれやとかね 言います
旅に出るならば今一番いいんだよと
そう言うと お釈迦様は気づいたんですね
やっぱり ああ これがまずいんだと
では行きましょうと それでやっと
だからあのお釈迦様さえも親の期待には応じなかったんですか
ですから 我々のことは何やと
だからそこはしょうがないんですよ
人間別々ですから あなたはあなたで
お父さんのプログラムには動けません
人は自分の業を持って生まれるんです
だから本人には自分の人格計画はあるんです
だから当然親と親が作る計画には乗れないんです
不可能です お釈迦様もブッダになるという計画を持って生まれたんです
これで父親が王になってほしいと
今更言ったってもね 生まれる前からの計画あるでしょ
あなたにも生まれる前からも計画があるんです
あんたはもういやおうなしにその計画通りに生きているだけ
全然親がね 恨み持ちませんよ
相当無知な親ならね もう怒るかもしれませんだけどね
怒ったっても恨みは持ちませんね
だからまず この親が怒ることをなんでそんなに気にするのかと
親が出ていけと言ったっても
なんでそんな気にするのかいと
へっちゃらで自分のわがままでいればいいでしょうに
そういうわけで覚えておいてくださいね
あの まあ人間っていうのはそれぞれ個人です
みんな業によって作られて
業を相続していて 自分の行為の結果を相続しているものなんです
だから 親にはどうすることもできん
業だけ自分のものなんです
親のものは相続しません
例えば 親が立派な画家だと思っても
生まれる子供 娘たちも息子たちもみんな画家になるという
このありえないでしょうに
あるいは親が何の学問もない
ただのもう畑ばっかしやっている人であっても
息子もそんなもんやってことはないでしょうに
日本でもね そこどこかすごい田舎
どこかの島なんですけど
あの子供たちが結構たくさん東大に入るんだと
いうニュースありましたけど
かなり前 しかし 親たちはただ普通に漁師やったり
普通に生活していて 息子はなんのことなく学校に行って
高校に入ったらもう大学
東大合格と いうこともありますからね
親がノーベル賞を取ったら
必ず息子もノーベル賞を取る
はあ 何考えているんですかね
やっぱり今日の 5つの箇条をね
覚えた方がいいんです
だから親は親で別人ですよ
しかし 一生懸命育ててくれたし
一生懸命心配してくれたし
そこら辺はまあ感謝の気持ちを持って喜べるようにしなくちゃいけないんです
面と向かって親に言ってもね
お父さん言う通りにはしませんよと
親がなんだこりゃとか思わないんです
だって親がね まあ医者になりなさいと言ってもね
まあ親の言う通りにはしませんねと言って
なんでやと言ったら だってできないもんと
言っちゃえばそれで終わっちゃうでしょうに
あれ面白くないんだと
ずっと見ているんだから
お父さんが医者だったら
どうせ息子も医者にしたがるでしょうね
だからまあずっと見ているんだから面白くないねとかね
それはと だからまあいろいろ工夫してる親ならね
微妙に暗示かけることできますけどね
親言う通りにやるように
だからまあ結論的なことは親を恨んではならんです
親は自分にできる範囲で頑張りました
親って完璧じゃないんです
親の間違い言ってはあかん
なぜならば自分が完璧ですかね
全くも完璧ない 完璧でない
どうしようもない子供が親が親のあれが間違っている
これが間違っているとかね
そう そんなこと思っちゃうとね
何の利武装ないんです
うん  そんなもんですね
まあたまたま電話かけたりとかね
年賀状を送ったりとかね
何かプレゼントを送ってあげたりとかね
そんな程度のものでもいいでしょうに
口で言わなくて ただ携帯ストラップ一つ買って送っただけでも
親がもう喜び喜びますよ
なんでこの田舎にこんなアホなものを送るんですかね
あいつはいつだってバカだろとか言いながら大事にするんです
どうしようもないやつやとかね
言いながら せっかく娘
息子 娘が送ったものだからね
だからみんな狭いだからね
もういろんな立場からものを見えないで
私はね もうそういう家族なんかずっと長く生きていたわけでもないし
結婚したわけでもないし
まあモテなかったでしょうね
で 子供は育てたこともないし
しかし 私は仏教のおかげで
このすべての生命という角度で物事を見るんだからね
見えてきますよ 私は親が子供に対してどんな気持ちでいるのかと
それよくわかりますし
子供が親にどのぐらい何持っているのか
それもわかっているし
いや 一般社会では親の気持ちはこう知らせるでしょうね
現実はそれなんですね
それ あまりにも狭いんだからなんですね
役柄を入れ替えて入れ替えてみる能力ないんです
だから結婚してもうまくいかないんですね
男は男の役柄だけでいるんだから
女の人が何考えてもやっぱりわからない
だからもう頭でこの能力ある人を役柄変えてみればわかるでしょうに
うちの家内 いつでもつまらない話ばっかり持ってくるんだと
仕事で疲れて家に帰ったら
ペラペラペラペラどうでもいいことをしゃべるんだと
うるさいんだと そう言うともう失敗でしょうに
役柄変えてみれば なんであの店の野菜が安いんだけど
あまり良くないんだとかね
自分がちょっと遠く行って
ちょっと値段高かったんですけど
野菜これこれ買ってきましたとかね
ダラダラそんなのうるさいんだと
男から見ればね しかし
その役柄変えてみれば
その人は一生懸命なんですよ
品質の良い野菜作ってご飯食べさせたいでしょうに
だから人の命を大事に管理しているでしょうに
そうすると会社の仕事よりもはるかにいい仕事をしていますよ
ただのキャベツでしょ
そんなのはどうでもいいんじゃないかと男が言っても
女の人はやっぱりもうもう 100メートル歩いちゃったんですよ
余分に だから男にそこを評価できなくなっちゃうし
だからこの仏教的に考えてください
すべての生命というスタンスで
親子関係ってなんでそんなにすごい狭い関係で
それでもうまくいかないとな
どういうことかな 人間っていうのはものすごい幅広い関係で生きていなくちゃあかんしね
だから親子 親とうまくいかない場合はね
社会ででもうまくいかないでしょうに
友達関係ででもうまくいかないでしょうに
うん そういう人がね 犬飼ってみたっても全くうまくいかなくなっちゃいますね
犬はまるっきり言うこと聞かなくなっちゃうし
猫飼っても同じ これ最悪ですからね
そういうわけで 皆さんはいつでも役柄変えるというね
変えてみるというね このシミュレーションですね
それやってみてください
どちらにしたっても この慈しみがないとダメですよ
慈しみできないと もう細菌だらけで
心は 慈しみを実践して
心が感染しない状態に作って
それからいろいろ役柄を
変えてみると 私はどこまでやるのかいというと
赤ちゃんがお母さんのおっぱい吸っている時は
どんな精神的な気分でいるのかということまでシミュレーションしてみるんです
だから気持ち私にはわかりますね
あの手やらね こうやって握ったりして
いろいろ捕まったりして
突然足を蹴ったりして
歯 1本ぐらい出てくると
赤ちゃんたちで何するのかと
おっぱい吸ってから噛むんですね
噛んでニコッと笑うんですね
それで期待してる 痛い痛いと言ってほしいんです
お母さんが まあ痛くないんだけど
そういうことで あの 動物を飼う場合も
やっぱりこのシミュレーションしてみないと
動物の自分が動物になってみるとどんなことかいと
まあ話は雪に伸びましたけど
やっぱり親の気持ちもね
ちょっと役柄を入れ替えてみるとわかると思いますね
ありがとうございます
それではあと一人ぐらい時間ありますけど
いいでしょうか 特に質問内容でしたが
香の門を行って終了したいと思います
それでは皆さんご起立ください
香の門 六方僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって生まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティヨイワージャントゥ サッバロゴーウィナッサトウ マテーバワットワンタラーヨ スケーディーガー ユコーバ
ワ バオトゥ サッバマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッバデーワタ サッバ ブッダヌバーヴェーナ サッバダンマ
ヌバーヴェーナ サッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー ソッティバワントゥ テアビワダナシーリスセ ニッチャンワッダ
パチャイノ チャッタローダンマワッダンティー アユアンノース カンバラン
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
では どうもありがとうございます